salut les épicurieuses et les épicurieux
vendredi prochain démarre en France la
dixième coupe du monde de rugby j'ai
hâte d'y être l'occasion pour nous de
revenir sur les mystères de ce sport
très populaire dans le monde entier le
rugby n'est pas un jeu de balle comme
les autres on fait des pages en arrière
on utilise un ballon ovale et en
pratique les mêlés rien à voir avec le
football et pourtant vous allez voir que
ces deux sports ont une histoire commune
allez on se retrouve tout de suite sur
mon terrain favori dans l'atelier la
partie va commencer
[Applaudissements]
d'où vient le rugby le 1er novembre 1823
au cours d'un match de football qui se
déroule à rugby en Angleterre un certain
William wadelys se saisit du ballon à la
main puis court à toute jambe pour
l'écraser dans leur but adverse le but
est refuser normal c'était un essai le
tout premier de l'histoire pour les
amateurs de rugby cette séquence
légendaire constitue l'acte fondateur de
ce sport c'est une belle histoire vous
ne trouvez pas et pourtant ça ne s'est
pas du tout passé comme ça
la naissance du rugby ne doit rien à ce
pauvre William weibelis qui n'a rien
demandé lui mais j'y reviendrai un peu
plus tard ce qui est sûr en revanche
c'est que le rugby est bien né de
l'autre côté de la Manche au début du
19e siècle pour développer leur capacité
physique les étudiants se retrouvent à
l'extérieur dans une prairie et court
derrière une balle au départ on joue
uniquement au pied toutefois les règles
de cette activité varient d'une
université à l'autre et deux courants se
dégagent rapidement dans un cas on se
cantonne à jouer au pied dans l'autre
les joueurs peuvent prendre la balle à
la main pour la passer à un partenaire
le premier courant va engendrer le
football moderne le second le rugby qui
voit officiellement le jour en 1820
porté par un collège situé dans une
petite ville bus centre de l'Angleterre
rugby les premières règles de ce sport
seront établies dans le même
établissement le 7 septembre 1846 et
là-bas aucun document ne mentionne
l'exploit de dans le web Elis alors
pourquoi lui attribue-t-on la paternité
du rugby tout part d'un article de
presse rédigé en 1876 un journaliste qui
prétend être un ancien camarade de
classe d'hélice il relate l'événement
vous savez la petite histoire que je
viens de vous raconter le joueur qui
prend le ballon dans ses mains et le
porte dans leur but le journaliste n'y a
pas assisté mais il affirme le tenir
d'une source sûre mais anonyme des
apparutions le papier entraîne une levée
de bouclier des anciens du collège de
rugby affirment haut et fort qu'ils
n'ont jamais entendu parler de cette
histoire elle est bidon qu'importe de
nombreux amateurs de rugby s'y
accrochent et la relève si bien qu'en
1895 c'est bien le nom de William
webbelliss qui est retenu par une
commission constituée d'anciens élèves
désireuse de mettre un nom et un prénom
sur l'inventeur du rugby mieux encore on
lui érige une statue à l'extérieur de
l'école et en 1987 on donne son nom à la
toute nouvelle coupe du monde c'est la
coupe web Elis du coup l'ancien élève de
la rugby School est entré dans la
légende bien malgré lui il meurt en 1872
4 ans avant la publication de l'article
qui va le rendre célèbre
rugby pourquoi fait-on toujours les
passes en arrière pour comprendre
l'origine de cette règle à unique dans
l'espoir de bal il faut revenir au
déroulement d'un match de rugby au
milieu du 19e siècle c'est un énorme
regroupement de joueurs qui progresse
vers le camp adverse en tapant au pied
dans la balle et en essayant d'aller la
capter quand elle couche le sol on
avance que de cette façon les passes à
la main ne sont pas interdites mais les
joueurs les évêques car elles sont
extrêmement dangereuses et pour cause la
loi numéro 27 de la rugby School de 1846
stipule que le joueur porteur de balle
peut être frappé au tibia résultat les
fractures à la jambe sont nombreuses
parfois très graves Henri vassal un
jeune étudiant à l'université d'Oxford
on a fait les frais au cours d'un match
il est victime d'une double fracture
tibia péroné incapable de revenir sur le
terrain pendant des mois il passe son
temps à jouer aux échecs et c'est là
quand on observant les pièces sur les
chéquiers il a l'idée le fou la tour le
cavalier ou la reine avance mais ils
peuvent aussi reculer pour mieux
esquiver l'adversaire et si on applique
à ce principe pour une bille en pratique
en transmettant le ballon en arrière à
la main on contraint un adversaire à
s'avancer dans le camp opposé un peu
comme si on voulait encercler le roi et
réussir un échec émane par ailleurs en
passant la balle vers l'arrière le
porteur est protégé par ses coéquipiers
ce qui lui évite d'être gravement blessé
grâce à Henri vassal et aux échecs le
jeu va prendre peu à peu sa forme
moderne en devenant plus fluide et moins
violent la moindre passe ou la moindre
maladresse qui propulse le ballon vers
l'avant et donc désormais sanctionné
[Applaudissements]
ils sont bizarres à quoi sert la mêlée
en cas de en avant la sanction c'est la
mêlée cette phase de jeu qui est
codifiée depuis 1872 donne encore une
fois au rugby son caractère unique les
Anglais
l'appellent la mêlée implique 8 joueurs
de chaque équipe les avants qui sont
liés entre eux sur trois lignes ils
savent goutte et entre en contact avec
l'adversaire les deux blocs s'encastrent
alors l'un dans l'autre pour former un
cercle fermé cela crée un tunnel dans
lequel un joueur le demi-mêlé introduit
le ballon afin que la première ligne
puisse lutter pour la possession du
ballon en talonnant avec l'un de leurs
pieds la mêlée est une véritable épreuve
de force qui vise à prouver à
l'adversaire qu'on le domine tant
psychologiquement que physiquement mais
les rugbymènes n'en sortent pas toujours
indemne Didier Gamet un chercheur en
biomécanique passionné de rugby a
calculé qu'un joueur
affrontent une poussée comprise entre
300 et 700 kg pendant 2000 secondes
c'est le point d'un piano à queue
résultat on recense en moyenne 16000
blessures chaque année dont près de 800
traumatismes du rachis cervical la mêlée
est aussi à l'origine
des oreilles en chou-fleur à force de se
frotter les oreilles contre l'adversaire
des hématomes apparaissent en termes
médicales on appelle cela une
péricondrite les vaisseaux sanguins
explosent le sang s'accumule et les
cartilages s'enflamment alors pour
éviter ce désagrément de nombreux
joueurs se protègent avec des bandeaux
ou avec des casques
pourquoi le rugby se joue-t-il à 15
1875 marque un tournant dans l'histoire
de rugby cette année-là le match qui
oppose les universités d'Oxford et de
Cambridge Aline pour la première fois
deux équipes composées de 15 joueurs
c'est une petite révolution dans le
monde de rugby jusqu'ici les équipes
étaient constituées de 20 joueurs par le
passé on a même vu des clubs alignés 25
30 voire 50 joueurs sur le terrain le
match Oxford Cambridge fait donc figure
de test et il enchaîne tout le monde les
joueurs mais aussi les spectateurs qui
réalisent que moins il y a de monde sur
le terrain plus il y a d'espace pour le
porteur du ballon l'essai est très vite
transformé de nombreux clubs imitent les
deux universités et la règle est
officiellement validée en 1877 à
l'occasion d'Angleterre Irlande le tout
premier match international à se jouer
15 contre 15 j'envoie certains venir et
le rugby à 13 c'est pas du rugby et bien
oui et non c'est un sport dérivé du
rugby à 15 mais qui n'a pas les mêmes
règles et qui a sa propre fédération
vendredi 8 septembre au Stade de France
c'est le coup d'envoi de la dixième
coupe du monde de rugby 15 de France
affronte les All Blacks autrement dit la
Nouvelle-Zélande depuis 1893 les
rugbymen néo-zélandais se présentent à
leurs adversaires entièrement vêtus de
noix une couleur qui est inspire la
crainte dans le camp d'en face ainsi
vêtu il porterait le deuil de leurs
adversaires comme souvent dans le rugby
ce n'est qu'une légende inventée par les
journalistes en fait le noir est un
hommage à la culture maori le peuple
originel de Nouvelle-Zélande chez eux et
cette couleur est symbole de prudence de
sagesse de Constance mais aussi de vie
mais il y a pas que la couleur noire qui
est fraîche et no All Blacks le haka
c'est la botte secrète des All Blacks
une danse ponctuée de crier de grimaces
qui précède chaque match le haka est une
sorte de trans les All Blacks scandent
les paroles cogne se rappeler bras et
les cuisses et fixent leurs adversaires
de leurs yeux exorbités littéralement le
mot haka signifie à la fois danse et
faire en maori il désigne les danses
chantées par l'ensemble des peuples
polynésiens lors des cérémonies des
fêtes de bienvenue ou lors des combats
dans le but d'impressionner les
adversaires le plus courant souvent
interprété par les All Blacks dit-on
substance gammate Kamate
je suis mort je suis vivant je suis
vivant les paroles auraient été
inventées par un chef maori en fuite
pressant sa mort prochaine il cesserait
écrit Kamaté je suis mort mais en voyant
ses ennemis s'éloignés il aurait
finalement repris espoir en chantant
kaora je suis vivant ce rituel a été
étrené pour la première fois par les
rugbymènes Néo-Zélandais en 1905 mais si
les All Blacks inspire autant la crainte
c'est parce que ce sont des rugbymènes
hors pair au dessus de la mêlée si j'ose
dire leur palmarès est impressionnant la
Nouvelle-Zélande est le seul pays qui
atteint 4 fois la finale de la Coupe du
monde elle a remporté trois titres dont
deux consécutifs en 1987 puis en 2011 et
en 2015
[Applaudissements]
voilà j'espère que cette vidéo vous a
plu et que le ballon ovale n'a plus
aucun secret pour vous je pense que dès
vendredi vous serez très nombreux dans
les tribunes ou devant vos écrans pour
soutenir le 15 de France n'hésitez pas à
liker la vidéo et à nous donner vos
pronostics en commentaire à dimanche
prochain et Allez la France
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]